is really dry I find that very dry
myself and I think you can allow
yourself to make mistakes this is only
about publications too because adults
they don't wanna make mistakes that's
like their big hang-up is that you know
a lot of adults they have their own
psychological barriers that are holding
them back and making mistakes is one of
them so if you even have tricks your
disposal to kind of eliminate the amount
of stake to make if you know that you're
speaking correctly it's gonna allow you
it's gonna open you up but that being
said it's okay for you to make mistakes
as well and if you know if you Mase
let's have a verb tense if you get a
masculine feminine wrong you're speaking
it's not gonna be the end of the world
right so I mean it's at what I think is
verb tenses you you can you know hey
have a sentence of your own pack in your
mind after having a correct sentence you
know to to just did you help you
remember how do you use the verb tense
and so you know there are things you can
do aside from that to improve your
listening skills so you can tell which
tenses are what you know what I mean
that kind of work that helps and so
having kind of you know their sleep what
they called cephas in french but it's
like if i did this i would do that you
know what i mean those kind of things
and so if you if you kind of practice
those and have those ready to go on your
own it'll really allow you to if you see
how the structure works and you can
adapt it to your own situation and so if
you if you start to you know if you're
having trouble with verbs i mean you
don't have to know all them to begin but
there's some verbs that some you know
are not useful for actually speaking
they're more written verbs so you know
right off the bat there's something
push aside and so concentrating on the
ones that are gonna be most useful to
you at the beginning you know building
your foundation up so you can kind of
kind of build on top of that it's you
know some of the ways you can even go
about doing it just like to add that you
know I agree you can't worry about
making mistakes but obviously if you
don't understand what the first is
saying that's not so good how often do
you listen a day tears back maybe once a
day on the radio what I would recommend
what certainly what we do it make is if
you can't understand the tenses then you
don't understand very well and therefore
you should be listening to a limited
amount of content over and over
listening to the radio he's not gonna do
that much for you okay and so you need
to take a limited amount of content and
listen to it 10 or 20 times and ideally
but again what we do in our system is we
have link we have this enormous library
of audio mp3 files for every audio file
and a lot of it is just ordinary
conversation a whole range of stuff you
pick something you're interested in
pick something where you like the voice
this is important because if you don't
like the voice and if you don't like the
subject you're not gonna learn and then
we will have a transcript and then when
you read the transcript what we do it
again to deal with tenses and even
collocations and so forth is you select
the words that you're interested in and
that will automatically grab words on
either side of us and you can edit this
and then so you start saving these
little collocations how you know if it's
a certain tense you know of some word
you'll see from the context because it
had yesterday written there you save it
and you study it a bit then you go back
to listening to it again and gradually
because there's no way I can tell you
from my own experience looking at a
table a conjugation table you think
you're learning it you can't remember it
it has it's not at that level that
you're gonna absorb the language it's
part of a context that you have heard
many many times where you can identify
with the whole context and that word had
that particular function and slowly you
start to create these neural networks in
your brain so to me a tense is no diff
from any other aspect of the language
you should learn it from at your level
if you don't understand the dense
differences you should be listening to
this limited content that you like to
listen to 20 times and then on to
another and another and another and less
than 45 minutes to an hour a day like
some people they want to see the word
and hear it at the same time you may be
one of those people you may not but some
people they really need to see it
visually in order to make that kind of
connection and so focusing on if you if
you're this to the radio it makes great
to listen to the radio because you can
hear different subject in different
topics and you get exposed to different
vocabulary but when you're trying to
build your own skills that you need to
kind of focus individually until you've
got it under your wing until you've
incorporated into your own kind of
routine your language routine you can
think of it then it just going to be
yours and so you're not only able to
understand it but you also can then be
able to use it too so by focusing
individually you then it's like you say
if you went to your taking some kind of
sport so you're doing fencing and they
talk to your mood you learn the move and
then you practice it right and then you
become part of your skill set so if you
learn a whole bunch of moves all at once
then it's hard to you know keep them
straight in your mind so you know kind
of doing it a little bit systematically
like that is actually very helpful
and so then it becomes wrong sorry I
drove it in the back
it's what we do is let the learner
choose the content that the learner is
interested in one of the major problems
in a conventional classroom is that the
teacher has plenty people in the
classroom the teacher said today we're
gonna study this and maybe the student
is not interested in this so first of
all let the person choose the content
they like let them choose a voice they
like in our system we don't ask people
to do things that many people let's say
so we ask people to do things that are
easy to do listen listen and read listen
and read listen to and read something
you're interested in that's about 80% of
what you need to do and the other car
seat pardon well that's right and then
when you read you select the words you
want to know and then we have flashcards
so that once you've selected these words
and you've collected the little
publications or phrases that go with
those words and because we're connected
to the online dictionary you can put in
the definition that you like we call it
a hint because the dictionary
equivalence is never one to one it's an
indication of what it might mean you go
through the flashcards which is again
quite addictive and easy too so what you
do is you let them do things they want
that they initially have chosen the
tasks that they're required to do are
easy we don't ask people - what was the
meaning of something or other if they
enjoy listening to it they're good I
don't need to ask them if they
understood the first paragraph or to
interpret we don't need any of that
listen to it if you want to listen again
you don't wanna listen to it again
listen to something else so the whole
idea is to to let people do things that
are enjoyable enjoyable tasks and if
they're enjoying what they're doing
they're likely to stay with it we cannot
create hunger some people who you know
someone who is not interested in the
language is not going to learn but a lot
of people in school if instead of
forcing them to get some grammar thing
wrong and that they're not
to get or get right they're not likely
to get right if we gave them the
opportunity to select something on music
on sport or whatever is a greater
likelihood that they would find that
interesting I don't know if that answers
your place the student is really the key
to their own success and I think that's
why we're really talking about the
student and trying to put them in
control zone the language learning
situation because they know what they
don't understand yeah you know what
they're having trouble with they know
what their strengths are they know what
their weaknesses are so there's the best
one to actually tailor the language
learning experience to their own needs
and what end what they want to focus on
so each in the person in this room has
different interests so if there's
someone who's interested in sports let's
say hockey and someone here and
interested in cars that's a way into the
language and that's something you're
gonna be more likely to speak about so
let's say if you like let's just take
cars for instance if you're interested
in cars you know you want to meet other
people who are interested have the same
interests as you
so you're gonna be more likely to speak
about that so learning about flowers
isn't gonna be as immediately useful to
you as learning what's something that
you're interested so if you can start
with something you're interested it's
gonna make everything I was like
learning instruction you can you can use
those to talk about anything that you
need and having a vocabulary specific
Tyrael and interests is a great way to
start then getting into the language
because you're already interested one
more thing I think that that Robin said
and that I agree with 100% anyone can
learn and one of the biggest problems
that adults have and I agree entirely is
that they don't think they can do it
they fundamentally don't think they can
transform themselves into a person
that's fluent in another language the
child has no such hangout and the adult
is afraid to sound foolish or whatever
the child has no such hang-ups so I
think a big part of it do is to get rid
of everything that's negative now you're
still not gonna get 100% of the people
who are hungry to learn a language but
in New Brunswick with 0.68% so I think
we can get up to ten